من رسام فاشل إلى جندي
بكى بحرقة
عند خسارة الحرب العالمية الأولى
وتوعد اليهود بمحرقة أقرب إلى جهنم
شيئا فشيئا،
جاسوس
ثم زعيم سياسي
ثم قائد عسكري
، ثم مستشار للدولة
ثم رئيسها
وهنا  نبدأ الجزء الثاني من حياة النازي هتلر وحرب الانتقام
التي راح ضحيتها ٦٠ مليون شخص
ولكن قبل ذلك لا تنسى الإعجاب بالفيديو
والاشتراك بالقناة وتفعيل الجرس ليصلك كل جديد
في العام ١٩٣٣
قاد هتلر حزب النازيين ليصبح
أكبر حزب في ألمانيا،
و أدى ذلك إلى قلق الرئيس الألماني باول فون هيندنبورغ
من تنامي الدعم الشيوعي، عندها قام بتعيين أدولف هتلر
مستشارا له،
وهنا بدأت قصة القوة الحديدية لهتلر
وأخذ وقتا قصيرا ليوطد سلطته وسيطرته
وخلال أشهر قليلة
، أصبح هتلر يتمتع بسلطة استبدادية مطلقة
واستطاع الدفع باتجاه التصديق على قانون التمكين
ما سمح له بتمرير القوانين دون الرجوع إلى البرلمان
وسرعان ما حُلت الأحزاب جميعها
وبقي حزب هتلر اليميني المتطرف
، لكن رغم امتلاك هتلر قوات كبيرة
لا زال يحتاج الجيش ليصل لأهدافه
حَذرُ قادة الجيش الشديد من قوات هتلر
جعلته
يُهدئ مخاوفهم تماما
لكن كيف؟
لقد قام بعملية اغتيال جماعية لرفاقه في الحرب
وكان من بينهم قائد كتيبة العاصفة إرنست روم...
وبعد موت الرئيس هيندنبورغ اتفق القادة على تعيين هتلر
رئيسا لألمانيا
وكان النازيون قد بدأوا خطوات إبعاد اليهود عن الحياة العامة
، فجاء هتلر وفرض إقصاء اليهود أيضا
ولكن بعزل كلي
حيث منع الزواج والعلاقات بين اليهود والألمان
أو من كان له صلة بالجنسية الألمانية
على الرغم من أن حبيبته الأولى
كانت يهودية
الهدوء الذي يسبق العاصفة،،
هدوء هتلر ومحاولته تأمين الدولة داخليا قبل التمدد خارجيا
أتى كل ذلك بثمره
وبدأت العاصفة في عام ١٩٣٨
عندما قاد هتلر جيشه  لغزو النمسا،
ثم اتجه لإقليم السوديت لضمه من تشيكسلوفاكيا،
ولم تجرؤ فرنسا وبريطانيا على اعتراضه
وهنا يوجه هتلر بوصلته نحو بولندا
فحاولت باريس ولندن اعتراضه هذه المرة
لكن تكتيكاته الخاطفة وعملياته المفاجئة والسريعة
جعلته ينتصر في المعركة
، وهنا  فقط، استسلمت فرنسا  وبدأ انتقام هتلر لهزيمة ألمانيا
في الحرب العالمية الأولى
وجعلهم يوقعون على اتفاقية السلام في القطار الذي أجبروا ألمانيا
على توقيع اتفاقية الهدنة فيه،
وذاق  هتلر طعم  الانتقام بانتصاره الكاسح
ورغم أن هيتلر قد عقد اتفاقية مع ستالين
قائد الإتحاد السوفييتي لتفادي الحرب بينهما،
إلا أن نواياه كانت واضحة بهزيمة جيش السوفييت الأحمر
، وما زاد الطين بلة، إعلانه الحرب على الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
إحدى أكبر القوى، فكسب بذلك عدواً قوياً آخر
وهو كذلك لم يستطع التغلب على الجيش الأحمر
في معركة ستالينغراد وتلقى جيشه هزيمة قوية
في ظل جوع وبرد وظلام وخوف في معركة تكسير العظام تلك
الفصل العرقي والتمييز العنصري
مبادئ لم يكتفي بها أدولف هتلر، ووضع قانون الحل النهائي
وما بين عامي ١٩٤٠ إلى عام ١٩٤٥،
صنع هتلر من اليهود حطبا لوقوده،
وقتل منهم ٦ملايين شخص ليطهر العالم منهم بحسب قوله
وقال مقولته الشهيرة
كان بإمكاني أن أقتل جميع اليهود
لكن أبقيت على بعض منهم ليعرف العالم لماذا قتلتهم
لقد نكل بهم في ما عرف (الهولوكوست)
المحرقة الأكبر على مدار التاريخ،
والتي ملأت قلوب اليهود بالحقد والألم
على مدى أجيالهم المتعاقبة
أُحرقت مئات المعابد اليهودية في ألمانيا والنمسا
، ودمر هتلر وأحرق أكثر من ٧٥٠٠ محل يمتلكه اليهود،
حتى أن  المقابر اليهودية لم تكن كافية لجثث اليهود،
وأصبحت مكبا للجثث المتراكمة
، ولبقايا الجثث المحترقة
قبل ذلك تم تجريد اليهود من ممتلكاتهم
ومنعت عنهم سبل العيش، وجعلهم يمشون ونظرهم للأسفل
ومنعهم من المشي على الرصيف،
وسحب منهم رخصات القيادة وأخذت منهم سياراتهم
وتم عزل اليهود تماما عن ألمانيا،
قبل ترحيلهم إلى معسكرات الموت والمحارق الدامية
وكان هذا هو انتقام هتلر من اليهود لاعتقاده أن خيانتهم
هي السبب في خسارة ألمانيا أمام بريطانيا وفرنسا
في الحرب العالمية الأولى
وهكذا سار حكم هيتلر وهكذا مضت سلطته
بين انتصار في معركة وخسارة أخرى
وإبادات جماعية
وقاد العالم إلى حافة الهاوية
وإلى هنا نكون قد وصلنا إلى نهاية الجزء الثاني قصة هتلر
وإذا أردتم متابعة النهاية والجزء الثالث ما عليك إلا وضع طلباتكم في التعليقات....